هو بير على مد البصر مئات العائلات تنتظر
امام مراكز احراق الجثث في هذه المدينه
قربشاي
نشرت هذه الصور على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تظهر حالات اكتضاض شديده في عده
مدن صينيه اذ لم تعود المراكز قادره على
اداره تدفق اعداد كبيره من الجثث موجه غير
مسبوقه من كوب التضرب الصين مجددا بسبب
داخل السلطات بشكل مفاجئ في السابع من
ديسمبر عن سياستها صارمه
م من كبار السن ينتظر المرضى لساعه طويله
قبل العلاج والعديد منهم يعانون من اعراض
الكوفيد الخطيره بسبب الكم الهائل من
المصابين يظطرها هؤلاء الى الانتظار على
الرصيف وضع كارث خارج عن السيطره كم هو
عدد المصابين اعداد لا تحصى
وحتى اعترفت بان حجمه فش المرض اصبح من
المستحيل تتبعه ومع ذلك يفضل التلفزيون
الصيني مثل هذه الصور لمماره خاليه من
المصابين في المستشفيات كما انه لا يبلغ
عن عدد الوفيات الاطباء من جهتهم يعترفون
بان ما حصل عام 2020 يتكرر قبل ثلاث سنوات
احصاء احتمال وفاه نحو مليون شخص في الصين
خلال الاشهر المقبله في وقت يبلغ فيه عدد
ملقحين 10% من عدد السكان